cinema I'm always trying to push the
boundaries and its really to give you
the very best experience the bigger the
film the more important to the theater
and transformers are big films I get
more activity from you guys come on
Jeffrey Helmick that is the very back
because you're huge on that screen
it's amazing the world that Michael has
created he continues to make them bigger
and better it gets bigger and more grand
every time you go out and I think part
of that has to do with how I max keeps
getting bigger and better
ready guys here we go
you're shooting with IMAX 3d I'm the
type that believes if you're going to do
3d you shooting real 3d we get that 3d
right here that means two cameras two
eyes and see exactly what you're seeing
and not faking it
that was always say our go-to camera a
camera always on the crane always doing
the big shot we strapped to IMAX Alexa
cameras together onto a 3d rig it has a
look like no other camera on the market
it's one of the most beautiful
incredible images you can see on a movie
screen
we are the very first blockbuster to
shoot not 10 minutes not 15 minutes of
IMAX footage but 98% IMAX footage IMAX
you really can see the scale you can
hear the sound and the hold experience
you get there that's a big deal the 3d
is phenomenal shooting 3d is harder more
expensive but it is so worth the effort
the operation is over we're not keeping
up up I'm okay
you
you